Lindsay Lohan has been making headlines
almost all of her life some good and I'm
not so good
listen that's why we are all so
fascinated with her she was one of the
biggest teen stars ever with a string of
hit movies including Mean Girls but then
she found trouble cuz I want to go on
the record Zack could not wait to do
this interview because I did sit down
with her Lindsay the very complicated
story and well the next chapter begins
tonight with the debut of her new
reality series fun in TV there are gonna
be people who watch this and say Lindsay
Lohan is opening a beach club a bar and
she's had struggles with sobriety that
was so in my past I'm running the show
so I have to be on it and I love that
there's nothing to do with my past
Lindsay wants you to forget her past and
see her in a whole new light as a
businesswoman boss [ __ ] Lohan's the
boss and her new reality show Lindsay
Lohan's Beach Club which follows the
actress as she launches a hot spot in
Mykonos and struggles to manage the
young staff
you're no stranger to drama so how much
drama
will we see well a lot because you know
there's these comparisons now with you
and Lisa van
well she's inspiring Lisa I just saw her
actually so we're kind of this is like
the baby version who the junior version
in a way I think that's a true strong
woman
yes lady I wanna build an empire here
the show sidesteps the act is his
personal life but Lindsay did tell me
she's single what are you looking for in
a partner someone who hates the
spotlight no seriously someone who
doesn't have Instagram like a smart
businessman so we're gonna sit down yeah
and she's been down the reality route
before Oprah took her under her wing in
2014 as Lindsay tried to turn her life
around what did you learn from that
experience with her just to take care of
me cuz I have a tendency to put everyone
else first so and I forget hi I need to
take it me time can we talk about my
favorite thing the dance Oh
[Applause]
just dancing that's what's funny and and
I would have never thought that that
would come out the way it did because we
were filming MTV and they would have let
anyone leak that footage so somebody
that I know must have done that I'm
never gonna live this down when you hear
dance like nobody's watching
that's what that
[Music]